okay everybody i am so so excited today
because i am joined by the one and only
teresa palmer aka rachel in the new film
the twin which is in theaters on demand
and on shutter now how are you doing
today teresa so good how are you doing
good um i first off absolutely love this
film and it's a tribute to how
incredible your performance is in this
film
so amazing but you have to go to a lot
of dark places in this film so i was
wondering when you read a script this
dark and have tragedy in it is it scary
to jump into that or does it excite you
a little bit of both i would say um i
get really excited at the opportunity to
sink my teeth into such a rich character
and i know what it means for performance
the things i can try and play around
with and
push myself out of the comfort zone
so that is all really exhilarating but
then it's daunting too and um a little
bit scary because
the subject matter in this story is
incredibly heavy it's about a woman who
has lost her child so her son dies in a
very sudden accident and it's completely
unexpected so she's navigating life now
with the weight of the world on her
shoulders grief and shame and guilt and
all the many things that come with the
loss of a child so it was a dark world
that i have to immerse myself in
um and i was pregnant throughout the
whole filming process so
you know it was a it was a rough one but
but also brilliant because i wanted to
tell that story and i find it quite
fascinating that
there are so many women around the world
and and parents you know dads and
partners and all those sorts of things
who they have to just pick up these
fractured pieces of their lives and move
on because they've got little children
to support and
nurture their surviving children so
it was quite a fascinating look at all
of that
that's interesting to all the things
they're saying because you know being at
the film is about motherhood as well and
you being a mom
did you feel like
that made it easier to find rachel's
choices in the film having some
experience then let's say if you did
this part you know years ago
yeah definitely
um i think just in general having
children has um
helped me in terms of reaching some of
the places i have to reach as a
performer
but certainly when i'm i'm playing a
mother
um i i know what it feels like to have
that unconditional love and that
infatuation with your children um
so the idea of losing that having that
ripped away from you and you know this
is a woman who's how she has to break up
with
seeing her child every day but the
dreams of who this little person would
turn into and how their life could
unfold
unfold and who they would
marry or what their life would be like
their career that it's it's not just
about you know everything that you've
lost in the moment it's about the future
of that child and what who they could
have turned out to be and
um it's just devastating to think about
i had to read
a lot of uh articles and journal entries
from women who have gone through it
because obviously i haven't experienced
that myself and i've got lots of things
to draw on in terms of that depth of
love but i don't have that same
sorrowful grief
so um
i
sorry i have a cold
oh no no
problem better
i like it
um yeah so i had to read a lot
to really get myself in that mindset and
um it felt
debilitating sometimes because
you get stuck in these feelings and it
was really really really heavy i had to
come up with ways to rid myself of the
feelings at the end of the day so i
could quickly shift into being mum and
put my kids to bed and um and once they
were asleep i could go back and explore
the
day's work and what i had coming up the
next day so
it was an interesting and challenging
period
that's interesting too because you talk
about going to bring the kids to bed and
you're mentioning the child in the film
is there a different approach you have
to take as an actress having your main c
scene partner be a child is there
something you have to kind of consider
when you do something like that
i think there's a certain delicacy that
comes with having your same partner be
10 years old
i
i was very maternal with him i wanted to
nurture him and take care of him in that
environment because it's not a natural
environment for a child to be
in and to be playing a role that's quite
dark and the subject matter is really
intense so i felt very protective of
little tristan and um i
you know it was it was beautiful because
my son and him formed a really lovely
bond my son would come to work a lot and
the two of them are a similar age and
they would run off and play nintendo
switch together and
play hide a hide and seek in this
ominous house that we were shooting in
um and that actually lightened the mood
a lot having the kids around and i know
the crew really appreciated it because
we were all just at this heavy dark
sorrowful bubble of you know this story
so
i was very protective of him and um and
i just would check in with him i just
always go how are you feeling
does this work okay for you like hey i'm
gone when i'm you know in the scene i'm
gonna hug you i'm gonna touch on your
shoulders i'm gonna rub you on the head
and um you know this is what i do with
my son are you okay if i pick you up
like this and just like really
communicating
with him um as a person with his own
little thoughts and feelings and i
thought that was important
yeah and i love that you like you always
do it seems like you do so much research
and preparation going into a part like
this and it's really such an impressive
performance so as someone who's kind of
a fanboy of theresa palmer is there any
kind of tidbits you can give like for us
simpletons any tricks you have or
something you kind of
do at every role to prep like anything
secrets to your technique that you might
want to share
um this one was where i felt most
liberated i think in my career in terms
of performance because um
as you know you've seen the film the the
lines between reality and fiction are
quite blurred without giving too much
away um so
it gave me the freedom
to dive into
so many
more bold choices and to get a little um
explorative with the things that i was
able to do um you know i think as an
actor your technique is like you read
the script like how do you breathe life
into this which is quite in a natural
way to make this feel real
um but in this situation i got to take
it the next step which is
how does it feel real but also
wild how do i make it feel a little bit
wild
um and that was really exciting and
sometimes i would try something and it
would not land at all and then other
times it would and then my favorite
moments in the film um from a
performance perspective but
i would say
using music is always a really good tool
to set the tone so sometimes i would
just ask them to play on playback
certain kinds of films that um or film
schools that were quite motive for me
that
helped dredge up feelings and emotions
and
and then doing a journal dump was
something else i did so
a lot of journaling from the perspective
of a mother who's lost a child and then
um and in this situation i read other
women's journal entries people who had
gone through this experienced it and
would specifically talk about how
isolating the feeling is because the
world you know the only constant is
change so the world is continuing to
move on and you're still
the center figure of this nightmare that
you're in
uh and that's incredibly isolating so
all of those things i i picked them all
and i and i tried to put them into the
performance
well it shows and you absolutely crush
it in this everyone make sure to check
out theresa kill it in the twin which is
in theaters on demand on shutter now
also check out her instagram her youtube
vlog she does amazing stuff for moms to
help moms it's really awesome that's
what's cool about you teresa you're so
passionate everything you're doing it
shows so thank you for joining me today
and i hope you feel better thank you
i really appreciate it steve have a good
one